please welcome to the show NOLA
Gallagher
[Music]
so so do you do you remember remember
the the election nights the night it all
happened brexit wrecks it yeah I was in
the studio of the day of the vote and
there was a voting station across the
road from the studio and I thought I
can't be bothered going to vote because
who'd vote to leave right so we were all
told that we would stay by a landslide
so it's carried on working kind of went
home and I went to bed at about 11:00
and everyone said we were going to stay
and that was it and it's grating and
woke up the next morning and the world
had changed and we've been in a mess
ever since you come from a very
different background than the Johnsons
yes yeah well did you that's not her
fault but do you have I mean having
growing up in a very poor environment do
you have an understanding of why it
happened at the time when the referendum
was called I was asked about it and I
said that there shouldn't be a
referendum because I don't think that
night that 99% of the people were
qualified enough to understand what was
going on and watching the debates ever
since in that analysis of Parliament not
even the people who were qualified or
qualified they say now
now we are voted to leave by hook or by
crook we have to leave because if we
don't we're not a democracy and if we're
not a democracy we cannot pontificate to
the rest of the world about democracy so
we have to we have to leave now
and make and make the best of it but I
kind of I think I hope in my heart of
hearts one day we'll go back in did it
did the question split your family as
well other things not well my my
immediate family I've got young children
me and my wife
no we we were we were I would have voted
I mean if it was a vote again tomorrow
I'd vote to stay I just asked you a
question hmm given that there was the
margin was quite slim and it's been
three and a half years right think of
all the 16 trees you know the young
people who could vote now and think of
the majority that has probably gone to
the happy hunting grounds so actually
there's maybe a majority in this country
to stay in but you think that still we
have to observe well I can't I hate this
term the people's vote we've already had
that okay I'm better off or worse the
people have spoken
they can't have referendums legal
referendums with illegal and then say
but actually we don't like while you
vote so we're gonna have to have another
one it's not fair it's not fair yeah so
I take it you don't want to leave the EU
if it was up to you unless you did ten
years ago you left the Oasis yes how do
you you it is ten years ago to this fall
and you it was very abruptly yeah and
some said it was brave some said it was
stupid
mmm-hmm what's your thoughts when you
when you think back I didn't think it
was brave or stupid it was just an
effort of all it was going to happen and
you know you get to a certain point in
your life was I
was 42 at the time and still really you
know if you if you if you're in a job
the mate that's making you unhappy at
that stage in your life you just got to
think well you know there's no point I
mean surely the pursuit of happiness is
is everybody's right you know I mean and
the way that it's been rewritten by the
other fella it's like you know you mean
your brother Lila yeah
all I did was leave a band that's all I
did him you know I didn't kill anybody
yet you know to some people it's the end
of the world you know it's the end if
the people can't will not still accept
you I got because they're like oh is it
well that's fantastic that's great
you know and I they've got the music and
they've got the memories if they ever
came to see us and all that but it was I
mean it was an emotional thing it wasn't
thought through was it well well it was
thought through very briefly in the back
of a car yeah it was sitting outside
look we're sitting outside a festival
that we were headlining was about 70,000
people there and it was a huge fight in
the dressing room and I sat in the back
of a car and I calmed down and my
security guard said are we staying or
going
and I made I'd been on the verge to
leave in a couple of times before and I
just thought tonight's the night I know
the worst thing was leaving the people
in the gig I that's I've never pulled a
gig on purpose in my life
but it was meant to be you know and I've
got no regrets at all so when from there
when was the next time you heard from
your brother did he try to call him I
got a legal letter from his lawyers that
he kindly managed to give to the Daily
Mirror the day before he sent it to me
so it was on the front page of the
newspapers and if you can believe this
he was going to sue me for libel for
ruining his character for me his
characters somewhat like slam de wave I
don't know what the legal term is you
know
so who who who would you prefer if you
had to choose who who would you prefer
to have as your brother today Liam or
Boris Johnson
[Applause]
hey Boris is more entertaining was use
of his use of the English language is
far superior
Lehman's better looking though so I
don't know I probably wouldn't get on
with these I think she's got magnificent
her she's got magnificent yeah we were
watching the the panel show on Sky me
and my wife recently what I do and we
both said she's got great hair what's
the thing with Boris yeah what about him
he's got an interesting haircut it's
like not sleep that is fire I don't
think it's he you can't shape it or
anything no it's not as it's not as
thick it's a different texture tell me
do you when you look back at those years
before the break-up with their voices do
you think about things you didn't
appreciate enough I don't regret a
single day being in that bound because I
always had to work I often used to feel
sorry for the other guys in the band
because I was the sole writer and I
always had to work to keep me grounded
but it actually kept me sane in a way
you know because I was I was busy
working you know directing it and all
that but I don't regret anything I don't
I don't I went there some things like
that I said about other people that I
wish I hadn't said and there's some
things that I did that I wish I did but
if I could go back and live it all again
I don't do it in a heartbeat from the
outside it it it looks like you are cool
as a cucumber compared to your brother
and I wonder today you have you have
three kids it's actually annoys him more
than you could imagine
in fact done well the [__] people think
that or the fact that you are that the
fact that I am NOT
because yeah because that can be you
know when you're arguing with some when
you're angry and the other person is
just like whatever
I mean it's infuriating of Christ which
is why he's so angry because every time
he sends out a tweet I'm just like I
mean always going on about half the time
cause it's super irritating I guess do
you not for me it's not I don't care for
me it's it's he's kind of taken this
he's kind of taken a kind of a insults
my wife a lot he's kind of he's floated
this idea that a lot of morons on the
internet have adopted this idea that oh
a system I want let me so there's this
fear that I'm at the kitchen table
saying please can I get back with Oasis
no please please please please no but
the thing is because like most of the
people who surf the Internet are morons
unfortunately present complete excluded
of course
unfortunately that's now become like
this thing you know Irene and my my wife
gets a lot of abuse which it's not fair
because she's it's cut nothing to do
with her at all and he threatens my kids
and all that kind of thing and it's all
gets a bit stupid but I would say you
grow up one day but he's 48 now yes yeah
the little pie left probably to grow up
am i doing his fifties men he's it
should be said he's not here to defend
himself tonight nobody's something we
want to be watching this now furiously
tweaking how but how as a father of
three how do you with that cool attitude
deal with the tantrum because all kids
have tantrums yeah well you see well
when my kids are tantrums I find
hilarious
like you know when they're kind of like
trying to hit you like a seven-year-old
trying to hit you and you're just like
the best way well they say the best way
to you know naughty children just to
ignore them you know what I mean III do
because I'm not on social media but it's
difficult sometimes I mean I need I it
has caused a lot of not upset but
there's a lot of there's been a lot of
things that have been said that are just
like you're not going to be able to take
that back you know what I mean and I was
born with one fatal flaw in my character
which is I will not forgive people I
can't do it there's something in me that
just I haven't got any forgiveness at
all that's why there will be no more
oasis I I'm very stubborn and what's the
line has been crossed I'm afraid I can't
I can't allow myself to to go back but I
guess if your kid has a tantrum you can
forgive my children yeah oh no I don't
speak to my children though
how will you make sure that your kids
stay friends but they're the same thing
won't happen again the file says one of
the fathers
well I our my children's life an
atmosphere at home was vastly different
from the one that I grew up in ours was
very dysfunctional family who when he
think about it now and never really
nobody ever really got on and I could
you know we grew up in the 70s and there
was a lot poverty and unemployment blah
blah knoweth what my children's home
life is very different they've got two
loving parents and you know they love
their stepsister and it's just it's a
different atmosphere you are a product
of your environment you know and if if
you're growing up in a house full of
arguments you will eventually become
like we became you know and if you grow
up in a loving environment you know the
people love and respect each other you
will eventually grow up
I mean and then as a pro you cross your
fingers and hope for the best chance I
mean you're both family people family
with with big families and can it
sometimes be too much I mean the
Johnsons are quite many there are too
many many would say I think it's hard
for people who marry into the family and
one of my sisters-in-law sisters-in-law
I love them all dearly though they're
all incredible women I was like saying I
you you guys coming to this or we know
the football or blah and I got this text
back from my brother Leo's wife saying
no this it's a JFW and I said what's
that and she said Oh date you know it's
a Johnson free weekend the in-laws have
this diet concept from a Johnson free
weekend where they like given a free
pass and they don't have to come to some
Sunday lunch or you know tribal and
gathering well I mean fighting in family
politics can be exhausting I don't know
how's Liam got kids yes many how many
officially for I believe so when you
your kids a bit younger possible yes
right yeah but aren't there are
occasions when you all have to be
together like weddings and then how will
that work no but nobody as yet to get
married yet so the situation has never
arisen but of course of course and it's
going to be very interesting because
that generation they don't see each
other either they do you my daughter is
20 we'll see and has gone to the same
school as some of Liam's kids when when
do you work apart from Tori when do you
write I write music every day
I never really switched off from music
it's because I don't have any hobbies I
don't mind my hobby growing up was
playing the guitar and I've been lucky
enough to know it's a profession you
know I don't I don't drive so I've not
got a fleet of cars I can just go and
take drive around Europe or anything's
you know I mean I don't drive or you
don't have a license to drive I've never
had a driving lesson it's never
interested me ever and did you buy a lot
of cars I did buy some cars yeah I had
when we first got paid properly I always
wanted a Jaguar mark - and I've found
this company that that found old cars
and put modern engines in them and all
that and I went to see this place it
took me three hours to get there in a
car and they were gonna they found this
thing and it was the year I was born in
1967 and they said we'll take three
years to build and I was like great I
like easily have passed my test in three
years and three years later I was in my
house in st. John's Wood and they lorry
pulled up with the car on the back of it
in the street another crop amazing it
get me one of those cars one and a guy
walked in with a clipboard says mr.
Gallagher there it's like it is I this
is your car and I've forgotten that I
bought and paid for it
I've still got it it's in a garage
somewhere and I think it's got like 12
miles on the clock so I'm gonna can't
leave these very good news very kids
well I'm gonna leave it for my kids to
fight over no it's fantastic to have you
on the show thank you so much I hope you
enjoyed the clip for more interesting
conversations please hit subscribe
you